[Musik]
das städtebauliche highlight soll die
neue zentrale straßenbahnhaltestelle im
niederrheinischen krefeld eigentlich
sein und schutz bieten gegen wind und
wetter
aber das funktioniert überhaupt nicht
die sich in diesen tagen zeigt unterm
dach tropft es und zwar gewaltig weiß
vielfahrer winfried komfort zu berichten
seit wir das dingen angeblich fertig
haben
wieso nur blödsinn nur chaos
da steht bei mir wenn wind ist was man
auf deutscher seite richtig kleinste
nach totaler schrott zügig es ist
einfach nur ungemütliche auf die bahn zu
warten
damit nicht genug nach nur anderthalb
jahren in betrieb sieht das teure design
dach aus als hätte es seine beste zeit
längst hinter sich
eine fehlende scheibe abgesperrte
bereiche und gerissenes glas der taube
prozent runter müll liegt herum
der 3,2 millionen bau ist eine
dauerbaustelle und die situation völlig
verfahren statt baufirma und architekt
streiten keiner will verantwortlich sein
für das besagte ein nagelneues dach bei
dem es reinregnet irgendwie riecht das
doch nach einer kolossalen viel planung
es ist keine fehlplanung es passt genau
hier rein und zeigt ein stück modernes
griffe modernes krefeld die firmen
reparieren nicht um die kommune traut
sich nicht einmal ihr eigenes teuer
bezahltes glasdach zu betreten und zu
reinigen
denn im rathaus hat man angst dass man
dann der staat die schuld für die
schäden zu schiebt die regenrinnen sind
verstopft überall läuft wasser rein aber
die stadt krefeld die tapfer zu ihrem
unfertigen neubau dass wir die
schwierigkeiten haben hinten mit den
glasscheiben mit den letzten das ist
sehr ärgerlich das gefällt uns natürlich
auch nicht aber die funktion der
haltestelle wird dadurch nicht in frage
gestellt so entspannt um die straßenbahn
kunden ganz und gar nicht
vielen geht es gehörig auf den geist
dass ein solches prestige objekt nicht
fertig wird und so verhunzt aussieht
diese dachkonstruktion bietet keinerlei
regenschutz bei regenwetter
es hat viel geld gekostet man hätte sich
vorher gedanken machen müssen wie lange
stand für die drei millionen hits
gekostet hat könnte man da jetzt in die
reparatur noch mal flott investieren und
das war jetzt auch wieder ewigkeiten
dauern
zumindest die regen sind land die stabil
zu sein
mit einer hebebühne will man den dreck
aus den abflüssen holen ohne das eigene
bauwerk zu berühren ihre aber wahr